[Music]
a 20 year old petrol station worker was
shot dead in germany after asking a
customer to mask up
[Music]
the country has seen many protests
sometimes violent over its hygiene rules
but the shooting was the first death
directly linked to the restrictions
it prompted widespread shock and
condemnation
only because we have measures that we're
supposed to follow
it's an escalation of conspiracy
theories
how can this radicalization be stopped
welcome to our covet 19 special today
focusing on how the pandemic fuels anger
among coronavirus skeptics right up to
the point of physical violence a
phenomenon all over the world
most demonstrations against coronavirus
regulations are peaceful like here in
slovenia but even this protest saw
pockets of violence
[Music]
in melbourne australia it was a
different matter
protests in mid-september escalated with
demonstrators targeting journalists
crowd is certainly getting bigger
they're very passionate
i've just been struck in the back of a
backpack of a head by a can
that really hurt
i've been i've been grabbed around the
neck today
i've had urine tipped on me
now i've had a can of an energy drink a
throne on me
just moments before protesters pushed
paul dowsley and his camera team onto
the pavement and threatened them the
organization reporters without borders
says such acts have become more common
everywhere since the pandemic started
including in germany
we're dealing with a new kind of
extremism here it's no longer just
left-wing and right-wing extremism and
islamism but a kind of conspiracy
extremism i'm almost inclined to call it
coronavirus extremism because it really
is an ideology of its own that's
establishing itself and is now
displaying violent traits and is acting
out violence
an ideology with a recurring theme
conspiracy theories
they say face masks are nothing less
than muzzles
that vaccinations will kill us
and the virus is an invention of the
powerful to repress the people
such beliefs make it difficult to get
covert 19 under control
and those subscribing to them can lose
all sense of proportion
there are public calls for murder and
revolution
so how can societies get radicalization
under control
well that is something i'd like to
explore now with uh pia lamberty and
peter knight pia is a social
psychologist with a special focus on
conspiracy theories she's written books
and articles on this topic
and peter is a professor of american
studies at the university of manchester
which also co-organizes the infodemic
project studying the origin of
conspiracy theories and how to combat
them good to have both of you with us
and i'd like to start with you pia and
your assessment of what happened here in
germany a young man being shot pointing
for pointing out the mask requirement to
a customer who then said he wanted to
set an example against the coronavirus
restrictions is this just an isolated
case some individual gone mad or do you
see a trend
um i wouldn't say it's an isolated
incident because there
yeah reason why the person shot another
man was because he said the mask was
um yeah a representation of supposed
suppression of
free speech and so on and this is
something we see through the whole
pandemic that the mass is politicalized
by populist parties that they use it as
a symbol to yeah portray themselves as
heroes and we see that there's a lot of
violence in the german society we have
so many incidents where people
are beaten up because of the face mass
we have arsenal attacks against
scientific institutions against vaccine
centers
against trains and so i think if you
frame it as a single incident that's
wrong and you ignore the violence that
we see since almost two years now
and peter i mean i know that there were
corona protests in the uk also in the
united states do you observe a similar
level of radicalization there
yeah just in the last week we've seen a
number of incidents for example
a man in maryland
allegedly killed his
brother and sister-in-law because his
brother was a pharmacist handing out
coded
shots vaccination shots in the uk there
have been online a lot of calls for a
second nuremberg trial
to
arrest and execute journalists and
doctors
so it can seem that
corona protests have become increasingly
radicalized but i think we need to
view this slightly more
skeptically vaccine refusal across the
eu
is at most
10 perhaps in many countries only 5
so we're talking about a small number of
people
who are taking these more extreme views
and certainly in terms of people engaged
in acts of extreme violence they are
still very very much in the minority in
a way that people
who are attracted to forms of right-wing
extremism
online
but it's it's all of this is all of this
down to misinformation as the who for
example uh
suggests or is there more to it why this
radicalization peter
it's not a lack of information when it
comes to conspiracy theories conspiracy
theorists
have endless access
to to information
instead i think we need to think that
conspiracy theorists are attracted to an
entire worldview a sense of identity and
no amount of fact-checking or kind of
information supply is going to change
their mind
okay so not even uh something that would
actually give them what they want appear
we've seen in the united kingdom a few
months ago uh the so-called freedom day
all the mask rules all those measures
were dropped
do you think would a similar move here
in germany eventually appease radical
corona deniers or would they find
something else to rant on about
i don't think that this will change
their mind when we talk about these
people with a strong ideology it's not
gone just because the measures are gone
we also see when we have a look at um
yeah the main
ideologists behind this
they are already claiming climate change
is the new topic and when we had the bad
floodings in germany they were spreading
a lot of conspiracy theories about
climate change so i guess these networks
are there
we can say that we have around about 200
000 people that are in these telegram
groups and channels um and at the whole
time confronted with these kind of
conspiracy theories and one problem is
they are not the majority of course but
they try to portray themselves as if
they are speaking for the people and if
they are the majority and in germany
they are very professional in doing so
and for example in berlin now they
changed the law that kids don't have to
wear a face mask anymore in school and
the reason was because people wrote so
many emails
that they don't want that anymore and
this has to do with the mobilization
from the spectrum we can see that in our
monitoring
all right pierre lamberty there and
peter knight
thank you so much for sharing your
expertise with us
there's so much more to explore maybe we
have another uh chance uh another time
because i'm afraid that uh topic will
not go away anytime soon so pia lamberty
peter knight thank you very much
thank you thank you
time now for one of your questions
here's our science correspondent derek
williams
[Music]
what role does social media play in a
lack of enthusiasm to get vaccinated
this is another question that's kind of
more socio-political that than
scientific but science does have
something to say about it and i'll get
back to that in a minute um first though
let's think about social media
seen from its most positive side it's
fantastic um digital platforms allow us
to share our thoughts and our beliefs
with our family and our friends and our
colleagues and the whole planet if we
want to um directly
instantly unfiltered they they let us
easily
create and and join communities which is
great
but that's also a double-edged sword
because researchers have shown pretty
definitively
that when it comes to big questions like
whether or not to get vaccinated
most of us listen first to what our
communities are saying
even if they disagree with expert advice
so if you're involved in communities
online where where pseudoscience and
misinformation
is widespread
then it'll probably have a big impact on
what you eventually end up believing
now the science um there are plenty of
studies looking at how big of a role
social media plays in vaccine acceptance
or vaccine hesitancy an interesting one
conducted in the u.s
back in december of last year for
instance
so right around the time that vaccines
were first being rolled out and people
were were understandably wary
it revealed
a fascinating split
its results indicated that people who
got some
or most of their information from
traditional media like newspapers
rather than social media that they were
also the people
most likely to accept vaccines the
authors concluded
that that's because traditional media
providers in general
rely more on data-driven content
and other studies have come to similar
conclusions so
so while social media brings us together
and has revolutionized how we interact
with each other in lots of positive ways
in many places it's also strengthened
the echo chamber effect and that
contributes in a big way to to division
on questions like
whether to get vaccinated or not
[Music]
more food for thought there and that
brings us to the end of this edition of
our kobit 19 special for me and the team
thanks for watching
[Music]